en plus des ukrainiennes ont confirmé un
assaut est en cours contre l'usinage of
talent de marioupol une nouvelle
tentative de moscou d'anéantir la
dernière poche de résistance dans cette
ville portuaire stratégique
le régiment azoff la milice nationaliste
qui forment le gros des troupes du
crédit n toujours retranchés à
l'intérieur à diffuser ces vidéos
montrant deux femmes victimes de
bombardements dans la nuit
ses deux filles étaient dans la cuisine
il n'y avait pas de soldats il n'y avait
pas de membre d'azov on se préparer pour
l'évacuation
le cauchemar se poursuit donc pour
environ 200 civils toujours abrité dans
les sous sols du complexe métallurgique
selon le maire de marioupol il estime à
100 mille le nombre d'habitants encore
présents dans le reste de la ville aux
mains des russes depuis la mi avril soit
le quart de la population d'avant la
guerre mais s'ils ne vivent plus au
rythme des bombardements elles peuvent
désormais ressortir à l'air libre leurs
conditions de vie sont plus que précaire
plus d'eau d'électricité ou de lignes
téléphoniques
la quasi totalité des immeubles détruits
face à la détresse de la population les
séparatistes du donbass qui ont pris le
contrôle de la ville promettent des
jours meilleurs
avec le soutien de la fédération de
russie un très sérieux et énorme projet
de construction est prévu que nous
pourrons voir dans un avenir très proche
mais commencera dès que le problème avec
asos talent et les nationalistes sera
entièrement résolu
l'onu espère pouvoir organiser d'autres
évacuations humanitaires d'une partie de
la population de marioupol notamment les
personnes ayant besoin de soins médicaux